shoes became important when Jordan shoes
became important not before then Michael
Jordan well it was interesting in the
Nike thing I think that was ambivalence
on Michaels part because Nike was a very
upstart company in 1984 they weren't
that established he wore converse when
he played at Carolina and so he kind of
wanted to stay with the converse couldn
t just like wear enough we had up gonna
converse and converse sort of presented
their image if Michael would be just
like everybody else that they had well
then it would be more of the same he
would be following me magic Larry Bird
Julius Erving was converse guy Larry
Bird was a conference guide Mehdi
Johnson was a conference guy did so what
and his dad asked the famous question
don't you have any new creative ideas
and they looked around like each other
like what does that mean like we're
gonna treat him like Bernard King or dr.
J isn't that enough and yes or no wasn't
enough we wanted to be different he just
didn't like the vision it was probably
an emotion a tough emotional decision
for him not to go that route but he
stood strong and and when he got the
best deal I told me he wouldn't have the
level of artistic freedom at a very
established company he'd have at a
younger entrepreneurial company well in
1984 Nike was that younger
entrepreneurial company they had a
bigger vision Nike willing to have
anyone transcendent store they needed a
Jordan and I felt that because they
needed him more that they would be more
willing to do special things for him but
Michael didn't want to visit Nike didn't
know anything about Nike he wanted to go
with Adidas that was his dream and his
mother literally had to make them you
know go get on the plane and go to
Oregon and go see these people and said
just just take a look and see it and if
you don't like it they could always say
no so he goes out there like a month
later to visit
and they put together a music video
where they put together a series of
highlights from college and the Olympics
they had the pointer sisters jump they
had van Halen jump Michael didn't crack
a smile the whole time and we went from
there into another meeting where Phil
Knight came in and went out for three or
four hours and I said like what you
think I thought I was good like cursed
me out because he didn't want to go he
looked like he was hating it and I
thought it was gonna be really upset
with me for forcing him to go to
Portland I said I don't want to go
anywhere else
this is it the reaction the shoes came
later and Jordan began to sell them and
everybody wanted one on the way in
that's a matter for me I think Michaels
brand and the creation of the brand
Jordan and turned the corner and that
changed it forever it was just a feeling
that it was a perfect marriage you know
a young player who wanted to start a
collection and they were a company that
needed a name star to catapult their
line and the rest is history
[Music]